[Music]
foreign
so here we will showcase the 15 biggest
sea monsters and Titans from the most of
us the super species we will rank them
according to the length and for some of
the entries we will take in height as
the measuring Factor anyway we will also
talk a bit about them just a tiny
statement each and then we'll get to it
at number 15 we have the Croc monster
this creature the lowest on the list is
already a massive creature easily the
size of a saltwater crocodile except for
it having longer legs that enable it to
run around chasing prey with speed seen
in the Skull Island animated series the
crop monster is around 20 feet of 6
meters long at 14 we have the Swarm
locals this is another Skull Island
aquatic monster that is also an ambush
Predator it is an insect super species
seen in the comics birth of Kong it has
an elongated body with many limbs
protruding from its sides akin to a
centipede it resembles a tree like the
sporemantas and it measures 8.5 meters
or 28 feet long
at number 13 we have the genital swarm
these are hyper carnivorous fish super
species that resemble the ancient
Dunkleosteus in shape and are larger in
size they are a very aggressive swarm
species and can attack anything inside
and they were seen in the comics
Godzilla Dominion they are seen to be
around 30 feet or 9 meters long
number 12 the giant shrimp these
specimens were seen in a museum in the
artwork for the comics of Godzilla
Awakening it seems to resemble a large
30 feet long armored shrimp with
stalk-like eyes
number 11 the siren Jaws this is a
massive 65 feet or 20 meters long
reptilian creature that bears a
resemblance to a crocodile but his body
is adorned with a covering of plants and
even trees on his back it possesses a
formidable set of Jaws filled with razor
sharp teeth and when partially submerged
in water it takes on the appearance of
an island utilizing this clever
camouflage to surprise and capture its
prey
number 10 the Maya squid seen in the
2017 Kong Skull Island movie the Maya
squid is also known as the gigantis
levipers and is a colossal 110 feet or
34 meters long developort subtitin
combining octopus and squid traits it
boasts of a bulbous octopus-like head
with 8 long tentacles it is also an
ambush Predator that can create a vortex
in the water with its jaws
number nine the mark Yeager Mark Yeager
was an aquatic reptilian Titan twice the
size of a giant whale she had a flat
elongated skull with various grooves and
bone-like growths resembling something
of a crust like a queen Xenomorph not
much is known about discrete except for
the fact that she was killed in a deadly
encounter with another Titan possibly
Godzilla
number eight the genital Alpha referred
to as a subtitle and due to not really
reaching the size of a true Titan the
genital alpha or the murder fish Alpha
is a gigantic version of the basic
genital swarm species and it leads them
as the hive mind it also has the
appearance of a Dunkleosteus like the
others and seems to be in the range of
200 feet or 61 meters long
number 7 the Kraken this developer
talent that was seen in the Skull Island
animated series seems to look like a
combo of different sea animals put
together it has a fish-like body an
octopus head and a lot of tentacles and
also crap like pincers it is also around
250 feet or 76 meters tall
number six the Leviathan this Titan was
mentioned in Godzilla kotm and was one
of the 17 talents that joined the hunt
with Ghidorah it was the cause for the
Loch Ness monster legends and was fully
aquatic but its size and design is up to
debate but since it is a Titan it should
be anywhere in this size range of 200 to
300 feet or 61 to 91 meters
number five Cilla titanosilla is a
heavily armored cephalopod Titan
sporting six segmented legs ending in
spite Claws and having a unique inward
curving shell resembling an ammonite
with numerous tendrils from its mouth it
is a scavenger measuring 341 feet tall
or 104 meters feeding on dead Titans and
can emit liquid nitrogen for some
apparent reason
number four I'm Hulu The Aquatic Titan
titanus amhulik actually is just a brain
or a nervous system that forms its own
body with telekinesis so in the modern
era its form is seen as a robust
partially human-like structure with four
legs and feet resembling three Roots
it's 379 feet or 115 meters long body
consists of a cluster of plant materials
that gives it the appearance of logs or
intertwined roots
number three Godzilla the king of the
monsters is pretty high up here on this
list since even though its 2021 height
is almost 400 feet or 122 meters its
body length including its very long tail
comes to around 800 feet or 244 meters
in length yeah we all know the
description and powers of the most
diverse titles Gojira so let's get on to
the next one
number two Tiamat closely resembling the
Kaiju Manda Tiamat is seen as a colossal
sea serpent with a dark purple body it
has numerous bioluminescent fins and
sharp blades and also sets of barbels
hanging from its dragon-like head it has
defeated a Kong in the ancient past and
took the layer the one where the Kong
defeated an earlier Godzilla and also
titanus Tiamat almost beat Godzilla as
well so it could be termed maybe as an
alpha specimen but as for its size it is
258 meters or 847 feet long and number
one Titans nakika nakika is described as
a colossal octopus or a squid-like Titan
with a protective sheller on his brain
in Godzilla Dominion his figures
unveiled showcasing a streamlined body
with eight thick octopus-like tentacles
adorned with hundreds of suckers and
Arrowhead shaped tips nakika is the
longest aquatic Titan with its
measurement reaching 898 feet or 274
meters long
and so those are the 15 monsterville's
aquatic super species ranked according
to size anyway I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit the like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates or new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam